the question of when does Life Begin
is a really difficult question
for me as an engineer and scientist
it's a philosophical question I mean we
could just go on population control not
like if abortion is right or wrong we
could say factually
the clinics were made by eugenics
for population control and it is
controlling the population as is the
never being given of 40 acres in a mule
so you don't have the opportunity and
when the people that do have the
opportunity are separated from our
people our tribe and placed in Suburban
communities next to us Chris rocker put
it the dentist and you know whitewashed
and made to shut the [ __ ] up and you
know vote left or whatever you know uh
[ __ ] are supposed to do when we make
it as opposed to
saying okay
we're building
schools we're building up choirs we're
building up our own leagues basketball
teams our own factories we started the
first
uh sportswear factory in America since
World War II
was actually uh this Factory I put in
Cody so
you know I'm 45 years old we're on this
journey right now it's the other thing
about this it's like
people just in general they love me so
much I'm like actually a hard guy to
really hate for a long period of time
just because like because of like my
huge [ __ ] and that's what I noticed I
didn't I didn't understand why he showed
it to me when we first met but now I
understand
yeah it's very nice congratulations